I want you to listen and try to guess who
orwhat this is.
(Chirping sound)
That was bat ultrasound,
recorded above your hearing range,
but slowed down so you could hear.
So that was an advertisement call
from the peak of themating season.
Scientists can decode these calls,
so a sample bat to English
translation would be,
"Pay attention.
I'm a Pipistrellus nathusii bat,
specifically male.
My name is X.
I am landinghere
and we share a common social identity
and common communication pool."
For a pickupline by a bat, not bad.
Scientists have recorded millions
of bat vocalizations likethis
and they've decoded many of them using AI.
And they've revealed that
bats havedialects
that they pass down from
one generation to the next,
and that babybats learn to
speak just like you did,
by listening to the adults around them
andbabbling back until they speak adult bat.